life is about taking risks and today I
want to talk to you about four different
types of risks we take
I'm Patrick big David your host evalute
I'm a weekly and today I'm going to
share with you a book friend of my road
called Samson syndrome his name is
Margaret Barry talks about risking it in
a way that I think is very appropriate
for me to share what everybody else he
says there are four different types of
risks the first kind of risks is
calculated risk this is where we are we
are kind of knowing the risk we're
taking but it's also somewhat calculated
starting a business is somewhat
calculated sometimes getting married
there's some kind of a calculated risk
to it second type of risk II talks about
is the necessary risk this could be your
vice president with a company and you've
been with the company for a few years
you'd like to become an executive vice
president there's three people fighting
for it and you have an opportunity to go
and expand a business in North Carolina
or Austin Texas or Phoenix Arizona
whatever it may be that's a necessary
risk to move up in the company and your
career so you take it the third kind of
risk is an unavoidable risk the drunk
driver rear-ends you can't control it as
an unavoidable risk the last type of
risk is the foolish risk foolish risk if
you have a hundred thousand dollars in a
bank you'd like to have a quarter
million you go to Las Vegas you put it
all on black and you'll lose it all that
is a foolish risk a foolish risk can be
you doing a video blog on the freeway
pendency you should focus on the road
yotz okay so good
so foolish miss could be you doing a
video blog you know on the freeway going
6070 miles an hour to probably have the
best idea to do something like that
that's a foolish risk so when you think
about all these different kind of risks
you realize life is about risk this is
what I could tell you the most
incredible fruitful experiences in life
have to do with taking risks but the key
is to learn how to manage risks in life
and once you learn that the odds will be
in your favor that's my message in the
week to you um please be sure to stay
risky and subscribe to this channel
you